cool thank you all for spending your 2
o'clock hour with me I appreciate it
my name is Eric Arby and the talk today
is on a wordpress in view j/s and we're
just gonna kind of dip our toes into
view j/s we could go really really deep
and get really complicated but I'm not
going to do that today I just want to
kind of let you walk out of here with
kind of an overview of what view j/s is
and how it can interact with your
WordPress website has anybody heard of
UJS before okay good all right for those
of you that haven't it is a JavaScript
framework somewhat new in the past
probably three issues three four years
if you've heard of react it's kind of I
don't want to say a competitor but it's
somewhat similar in a lot of ways it's
not but it kind of is it's another
JavaScript framework so without further
ado let's dive into it I've got exactly
25 slides so if I take a minute each
just 25 minutes so we'll get you out of
here nice and quick so anyway my name is
Eric Arby you can find me on Twitter at
Eric Arby I've been building websites
for about 10 years now almost
exclusively on WordPress
I've company called Gulf web design we
focused on the golf industry that's
still going on and more recently I've
started another company an online
mattress company we run everything on
WooCommerce if you're familiar with
commerce ecommerce solution for
WordPress and so I love to just dabble
and tinker with new things and build new
technologies so when view j/s came out I
thought it was pretty awesome
so that's why I kind of want to share it
with everybody here today so again thank
you all for being here and letting me
share this wonderful information with
you again today's goal WordPress as our
database right UJS we're kind of gonna
use it as the the view layer so
basically it's going to be a kind of our
interaction layer and our presentation
layer the way I use it with WordPress is
different than some other people may use
it but I'm gonna show you how I've done
it and a few projects actually one in
particular that I've built a directory
website that uses UJS with
WordPress as the backend so and I don't
know maybe you guys tell me what's
easier to see is that easier on the eyes
than the white yeah is it hard to read
okay
so we'll keep it we'll keep it like that
I wasn't sure which one would be better
yeah that's better I think I can
probably could there you go yeah okay
cool so UJS it is a progressive
framework it's a simple or complex as
you can as you want to make it that's
what I love if you're familiar with
react react is pretty complicated you
have to have a build process with view
j/s you can just drop it in very similar
to jQuery it's it's very very similar
you just drop it in and go and that's
what makes it wonderful for working with
WordPress at least just kind of dipping
your toes in and getting started with it
that's exactly what I said it's easy to
maintain it's very legible once you kind
of get past like the learning curve of
you and you see what it can do and how
it's built and how its structured there
is like a slight mind shift you need to
have coming from jQuery and traditional
you know kind of manipulating the Dom
versus writing in view but once you get
past that you're like wow this is really
easy
I can almost you know just start right
up and go from this I've heard you know
a different debate about developers or
beginning developers you know if you're
just learning any language especially
JavaScript what's better to learn a
frameworks I learned plain vanilla
JavaScript you can almost jump right
into view and start learning right away
my niece is right here she could start
learning this immediately yeah that's
what we're working on next after
WordPress so anyway that's just a script
tag of how you'd include view really
really simple again you don't need a
build process view does have a CLI
command line interface that you can use
to compile a whole view app but we're
not going to get into that but just so
you know that that is an option all
right so this is kind of neat one of the
I'm just going to dip interview a little
bit and then we'll talk about how it can
interact with WordPress so you see the
the double curly braces that's something
if you've never seen that before in
any other language or in the other
programming language you might be like
what the heck is that and why is it not
out here on my HTML well because that's
that's view view is actually integrated
in your HTML as well as you can see this
is just a little code pen here just to I
made a gif you can see when we update
the actual data model here the text it
updates where that text is on the actual
screen so they can take second there you
go
that's as hello there so that's kind of
an intro to the syntax is the double
curly braces they're two-way
data-binding alright so this is kind of
neat this is like interactive this is
like you know this is this is beginning
to see like alright what can view really
do and why is this cool at all I don't
know because you can actually enter in
text and see it somewhere else on the
screen that's kind of neat right that's
that's two-way data-binding so it's it's
instant it's instantaneous
now this might take a second because I
am on the Wi-Fi here I don't know if I
need to tether I'm sure some other
people have had issues with the Wi-Fi
being a little slow there it is I do
have this is like a little bit of
interactive I don't I didn't want to do
live coding in this talk but I planned
on doing a little bit something so here
we go
now I can actually go hello everyone
right that's kind of neat so if we look
at the JavaScript for this super simple
that's it
that's super minimal now if I look at my
actual HTML again I'm using the double
curly braces here see my input text
there this is the mind shift that I was
talking about if you're used to you know
jobs are jQuery or JavaScript I guess
plain JavaScript manipulating the Dom
the actual document object model you
don't have to do that here with view you
can actually insert some special tags
into your HTML you can see my input type
can everybody read that is that big
enough I'm referring to the the v-model
right here that's something you've
probably never seen if you've never seen
view before you're like wow this is kind
of weird so the model is actually going
to
and whatever I'm typing into that input
box with what's in the curly braces
there are the double curly braces so
that's it I don't need to do anything
special view picks up everything else so
now I can just as I type there it is
so it's kind of a little bit magical
you're like probably like wow what's
going on how is it even doing that but
that's how simple it is if you've come
from a plain vanilla JavaScript or
jQuery world this is like wow it's so
easy that's why when I saw it I was like
blown away
speaking of jQuery I'm going to compare
compare the two here a little bit and I
promise we're gonna get into WordPress
in a little bit here as well you're kind
of like ah so much JavaScript okay
we're gonna get into WordPress in a
little bit but I've used jQuery a lot i
build custom themes a lot custom
WordPress themes a lot and I'll use
jQuery for a lot of different things you
guys might use them for sliders or for
different interactions here and there
that's you know this is the mind shift
here so I'm going to compare the two you
can see the weight of both of them
exactly the same I'm gonna walk through
a little example here of something you
would do in jQuery and then something
you would do in view j/s so something
you do in jQuery right here would be
exactly what I just showed you in this
little example right here of typing and
it gets manually entered out on the
screen right you kind of see all the
code necessary there you've got a
function you know every time you're
basically performing the KeyUp function
this is going to run and you're
basically going to grab the value and
spit it out you're gonna append it to
the actual HTML there's my HTML up there
whereas we happen to view it's very very
different we're gonna add those elements
like I said the v-model
into our HTML and look how simple and
clean and tiny that javascript is super
tiny so again like I said even for
beginners learning this once if you have
a good teacher if you have some good
tutorials that you can find it really is
a lot
I shouldn't say easier but a lot more
simple to understand and the graph
the concepts behind it so don't be
discouraged if you do dive into this
don't be discouraged by kind of the
initial hurdle to get over
alright so Google says that the most
popular thing that people use jQuery for
is toggling a class that's what Google
says which is kind of funny and I'll
show you a little example in a second
but this is how you do it in jQuery
you'd use the toggle class function so
basically every time I click my button
class then the dot toggle class my
paragraph there changes the class to red
if I show you that in view its again
look how tiny my JavaScript is all I'm
doing is setting active active as a
bully in there teaching my niece about
boolean true and false earlier um all
I'm doing I'm actually got a special
parameter in view there called the at
click and I'm basically saying if it's
active make it you know remove it if
it's not added and that's it so I won't
go all into that but that's roughly what
it's doing so we get a little example
here click it uncle' super simple
there's my java script again minimal
that's it
HTML that's it it's super duper simple
so when I saw this it blew my mind even
these simple tutorials these simple
examples the mind shift from from
vanilla JavaScript really is very very
different
next all right now we're going to
finally get into WordPress a little bit
what you guys are all here for so how
you would include it and yeah you can't
include it is just like you would in
queue any other script and do your theme
again I do a lot of custom theming so
you would include oops that are right no
no no doesn't require jQuery I'm sorry
sorry I'm just if you were using jQuery
and your theme you what you would in
queue it just like you would jQuery or
any other script I should say yep so a
little a little error there we didn't
didn't catch that I
justno all right so this is a website I
built again I told you I was in the golf
industry and we built a little view and
WordPress app for a directory the
Northern California Golf Directory and
basically what happens is they've got a
huge database if anybody's worked with
with clients that have just a large
database of things of places a list of
lawyers any kind of directory anything
like that view would be great for
searching and sorting on the front end
and that's pretty much what this was so
this is a directory of golf courses in
the Northern California area and each
one basically has a profile right and
I'll listing and a latitude longitude
you know an address so all that data is
stored in WordPress we use the custom
post type if you're wondering use the
custom WordPress impose type in
WordPress called golf course and had
just basically all this data we used
advanced custom fields to you know can
hold their website their you know
address all that fun stuff and on the
front end this form is built you can see
it's pretty pretty quick it's using Ajax
to return those results and display them
so all this right here is using view to
display these these nice little you know
little boxes you click there it loads in
the actual post type page or it has all
that data the Google map loads really
slow I mean corporative Google Maps and
do it with JavaScript pretty basic stuff
from from like a high level but view Jay
s made this so simple and in actually
how we were able to perform this search
and get our data back yes
mm-hmm we did that's exactly right yeah
so the question is did we update the URL
when somebody goes to that like single
golf course like this quail lodge here
and we did do that and we're actually
using the push State and pop state to
keep track of that view does not add it
out of the box like view just including
it like this it does not it does not so
that's something that we had to manage
yeah exactly but basically he's asking
is so when you click on that single golf
course page you know if you're using
Ajax and it just loads it on the page
you're like oh I want to send this link
to somebody well if you're using typical
Ajax that link would just take you back
to the home page so then your customer
really where is it I'm just looking the
home page I'm not looking at quail Lodge
which I wanted to look at so we did
handle that through through the state of
the the URL browser or the URL next
alright another concept that I want to
show you in view that's it's very very
awesome and if your PHP developer at all
you may have used this before or even a
JavaScript developer you're probably
familiar with kind of a for loop and
what this it's again it's really a mind
shift because you're like normally what
you would do is sort through results if
you're familiar with the WP query you're
gonna you know loop through results and
display them out you know if I want to
get all my list of posts or loop through
each one and maybe spit out the title
well you would do that in PHP we're
doing that here in the HTML with view
see my my v4 statement right here
result in results I'm actually able to
do this right in my HTML so as I'm
writing my HTML I can spit out this loop
here hence you know you see the the
double curly braces right here the
results dot title result that address
that is actually my data being spit out
on all on the view layer or on the front
end layer exactly
those though that's the actually
WordPress title but those are the custom
fields like the course type the address
the city things like that yes exactly
but the the whole concept of actually
being able to loop over items directly
in your HTML as opposed to looping
through them in the PHP and then
spitting out the proper HTML that that
needs to format those correctly is
definitely a big shift so when I saw
that and I was like oh this is this is
really something that could um kind of
cut down on development time obviously
the learning a learning curve is a
little bit once you get there you're
like okay wow this really really makes
sense it's like I said if you venture
down this road stick with it because it
gets easy and then shouldn't say easy it
gets more simple and then it really is
kind of fun to play with from there so
any questions on kind of like looping
over items like this because what this
spits out is basically a list a whole
bunch of Li items you're seeing there
okay yes so how does this how does this
integrate with WordPress what I'm doing
here yeah sorry I did not explain that
this basically is looping over my
results and I stored my results I went
there's a separate kind of Ajax call
that requested all of my posts from
WordPress and return them as a view
object called results and that's what
I'm looping over so I don't have it here
I may have it another slide but
basically we're sending an ajax request
to the server to wordpress to return
those results as a json object and then
actually I do have that I'll show you in
a second good question any other
questions on kind of the v4 on building
a loop like that yes
right
that's that's well that's definitely
concerned attack of the last part he
asked is there a basically an advantage
or disadvantage of looping over data
like this on the back end on the server
side versus on the front end side so yes
the one thing on the front end side is
you want to make sure that your your
clients browser can handle something
like view it is a modern framework and
there are fall backs but you can kind of
progressively enhance or allow for those
I guess so that is definitely concerned
what your clients are running now I
wouldn't say a huge concern because view
is pretty compatible a lot of things but
sure that I mean definitely from
anybody's if you're building enterprise
things that could be a concern as far as
the data goes you know serving it up on
the back end and then displaying it on
the front end you're still getting that
data somehow so honestly I like this way
and I shouldn't I'm not a proponent
either way and saying this is better but
this is kind of nice because from here I
can manipulate it further whereas on the
back end I have to do those complex
calculations and whatnot and then spit
it out and if I want to rerender that do
one little manipulation you know filter
through these I can still do that on the
end on the front end because all that
data is right there does that make sense
so that is kind of one advantage is you
can do more data manipulation from here
on the front end versus having to make
another server-side call and spit that
back out to the browser right yes this
exactly so the question was are you
always making a call to all the results
and then you know filtering from there
no no that that is those results that
are being returned from the browser are
usually just based on like that search
query so just return results within you
know an X amount radius of the city that
you type in so you're not getting like
the whole thing exactly and then
displaying on yes exactly
oh yeah view is built for modern
browsers I believe ie 10 I'm not exactly
sure the backwards compatibility with it
it's a good question though I should
check that out
obviously edge works pretty good with
edge yeah the question was is it capable
with all versions of Internet Explorer
good question Wow if everybody didn't
hear that she's talking about a client
who has a tesla browser a tesla car in
the browser in there it's a great
question I don't have the fun advantage
of being able to test on a Tesla yet I
wish I wish I did yeah go to the
showroom just to test a webpage that's a
good that's a good reason to go to the
checkout at Tesla absolutely well I'm
sure they release you know what browser
is in isn't there yeah yeah so alright
so again going over kind of the v4 I'd
dig into this deeper here this is
straight from the view Jas org website
or is basically in my example or in the
website that I built I was actually
pulling I was getting an Ajax response
here the data is listed under items
right there this is just an array
message foo message bar and so in my
HTML I'm using the special v4 tag to
loop through those items and then
display the item that message so that's
kind of just a simpler way to see and
then here's the result boom boom one two
just kind of a recap of exactly what
what we went over I see a hand raised no
okay alright so getting data from HR
from WordPress this is kind of where I
was talking about how do we actually get
that data so what there's two ways right
off the bat if you're building a custom
theme and you want to get your view j/s
data there's two ways to kind of build
it in without doing the whole build
process and going into really diving
into that
doing a standalone kind of spa which
we'll get into later on but you can use
the WP Ajax action or the REST API two
different ways you can pull data WP Ajax
is exactly what we used in the the
directory that ncg a directory there and
basically you're creating an action with
a special like function that you create
I won't get into it too much I'll just
give you a high-level overview you
created a function in the functions dot
PHP file to say alright query all of my
golf course posts and return this data
in this special format that's how we use
the WPA checks the rest API is really
really cool and I'll show you an example
in a second of that they might use the
REST API in any projects at any level
yes it's it's a little faster yes yes
yeah there's definitely some advantages
so this from our Ajax response this is
what we got for our golf courses this is
like I said this is the function that we
created to return this data in this way
so it's all just custom you know post
type data custom meta fields that we
created city states hit lat/long and
this is kind of when you ask the
question about what are our results
looking at we returning all them to view
and they're filtering there no not
necessarily we're returning exactly what
we searched for and this is what it gets
formatted like so in my V for loop I'm
looping through each one of these
objects and then I'm saying result dot
title result titles at that tail I'm
spinning all out now you've also got the
I know that's really tiny to read you
don't need to read all that but you can
kind of get the gist what that
structured like this is your WP REST API
response so if we want to get a little
bit more advanced that there is all the
content that you're seeing here that's
being spit out and returned to you is
probably a waste a lot of it is a waste
or as what I just showed you this is way
more efficient this is exactly what I
need but in the REST API model I don't
need to know that the author was one or
the comment status was open that's kind
of wasted data coming down the pipeline
right so if the graph QL is pretty cool
never used it before but the promise
there is that you get returned only the
data that you need and it's fast
like the rest API so anyway just a kind
of a side note there but this is the
response that you could get and then
view J s can easily handle this is this
just a JavaScript object and you can
easily reach in and grab anything you
need here with UJ s that's again well
the really really nice things about you
all right 2:25 already man I should be
done we're almost there
all right so template dot view this is
just a real quick overview of what a
template page and your custom WordPress
theme can look like you get the header
you get the footer pretty simple stuff
div ID equals app right we need that
because we're saying in our script your
new view element equals ID f right so
that that ties it to that do anything in
that div ID app that's all going to be
like a view component that's all going
to be used you can access anything in
there from view again here's our data
you can loop through it however you want
however you get the data whether you am
slap it straight in there use a PHP
function use an ajax request however you
do it now it's basically accessible in
that div ID app so view J s can also be
a standalone single page application as
I was saying earlier there's a whole CLI
command line interface for it where you
can scaffold entire pages there's
routing there's there's everything that
you want to do as a standalone kind of
website and you can use WordPress as
basically your data store and pull your
data from that REST API that WordPress
spits out so this presentation actually
built exactly like that
this this presentation I'm going back
and forth I use the key up function and
you can see I had to use my niece's
computer because mine had a USBC
connection so I'm more hurt but you can
see that I am just flipping through this
is just an index that HTML file and I'm
using the hash tag there 22 is the 22nd
slide WordPress is powering all the data
that came in to each slide does that
kind of make sense and all I did for
that was used a local version of
WordPress I used this is kind of a neat
little local dev tool called local by
flywheel if you've ever heard of this
who ever heard a MAMP WAMP basically the
same thing lets you run WordPress
locally so I just set this up and that
was it all my data is in there and I
will show you that right now there's all
my posts each post was or each slide in
this in this deck in this presentation
was a wordpress post and as all spit out
right here anyway
mind blown all right so that is roughly
we can dive into that if you any
questions about like how that was built
and how that gets pulled in and
everything I did create a few just like
three pens on code pen they're really
really easy they're really simple pretty
much exactly what I showed you things
that do basic functionality like this
the two-way data-binding right here um
spits it out right there those are all
in code pen if you guys want actually
check out the actual code and then I put
up just some simple links this slot this
deck is available but the pictures won't
work if you are interested would anyone
like that you never know I mean I don't
know if people actually care about that
or not
slides dot Eric a RBE that is the URL if
you want to check out those links as
helpful links to learn more about view
it's pretty cool but check that out I'll
upload of that last night not not
thinking that people would want my
slides I was like oh it's just gonna be
all local it'll be really cool or off to
rely on that connection and then I was
like well what do people want the data
so anyway you can go there and you'll
see it but the pictures won't load but
you can still get to the last slide so
you know really slow data here I'm Wi-Fi
so any questions anything else that was
my pitch promised one half hour yeah
hybrid that you're gonna actually turn
into like Navy Cove and put on the App
Store and everything that I don't know
because I'm not sure how it works with
compilers but I bet it would work pretty
good I haven't really worked with them
too much but I know the ones that kind
of kind of wrap your HTML and everything
into like native Xcode and push it out
to the store I'd imagine I mean it's
super modern it's a fantastic framework
I imagine it would work really well so I
don't know for sure though good question
okay the question is will a conflict
with jQuery if you have both of them
running at the same time no actually on
my ncg a directory I had to run both so
they do work hand-in-hand jQuery and
view yes
the the question is with with Guttenberg
being built in react will that have any
conflict with view no as far as on the
front end you're still just receiving
data you know on the view really is just
a view layer so anything that you're
receiving from WordPress is really
coming out as data so unless you're
trying to do like built a plugin with it
there's something on the admin side
possibly but as far as I can see there
should be no conflict with with how
Gutenberg's being built and building
view into your own theme but again I
have really not dove into guttenberg
super deep so maybe at some point I
don't know but I doubt it especially if
you're using like I said just on the
front end just a view layer you should
be totally fine yes
yes yes no the question was can our
clients edit all that golf course data
absolutely that's the beauty of it they
can log in right to the back end of this
this is basically what it would look
like this would be like Pebble Beach
Golf Course Quail Hollow Golf Course
they can log in and edit that what I was
showing the the JSON object that's
returned that's just how we're getting
that data from WordPress but yes it's
spitting it out onto an actual dot JSON
file yes so making that without was the
goal was to make it so they can edit the
backend of those golf courses really
easily if anything changed yes yes sure
sure sure the difference is the the
question was where the differences
between using WPA checks versus the rest
API
WP Ajax in my opinion and using it for
this project was again the first thing
was you're able to spit out the data
that you need you can build a custom
function that runs a custom WP query and
returns only the exact data you might
need the REST API you're gonna have to
install another plugin if you want to
get a CF data advanced custom fields
data or if you have any other kind of
data you might need to manipulate the
REST API in order to get the right
response you're looking for so that
that's a little bit plus the endpoints
for the API they're not I don't think
the WordPress documentation is great yet
on that how to access those those
endpoints where as an Ajax function to
be you know the admin Ajax you can like
I said it I feel like it's slightly more
customizable but I'm sorry
no no not at all that's the thing it's
it's been all depends on what you need
if you just need basic data from from
your posts the REST API is a fantastic
way to go and that's how I did my slides
here I use the REST API just put that
information out yeah so as far as
performance wise I have yet to actually
like clock them both and see which one
is faster I would think the REST API
should be a little bit faster but I
think doing it like an Ajax function
like that could depend on your server
too and then how big that process is I
know for our golf course process I had
to install a special plugin that took
your current or the the user's current
latitude and longitude and measure it
between where the golf courses latitude
laundry was last through to us so that's
a pretty advanced like algorithm to say
all right how far am i from you based on
your latitude and longitude it's you
know they got to cover the the curve of
the earth and all that fun stuff so if
you're running you know an algorithm
like that that could be pretty server
intensive so but I couldn't do that with
the REST API that's why we had to do
that any other questions
on the back end yeah yeah yeah so so for
the camera the basically the sentiment
was that the rest api is better for
long-term projects it's probably gonna
be more stable right less things could
break versus your own custom function
where it's potential there yep so
they're kind of different but you can
build out a custom theme on the front
end with view j/s and have that somehow
integrated with WooCommerce absolutely
we're not using I use WooCommerce for
one of my WordPress websites yes for one
of my businesses but on that website
we're not running phew but you usually
could you absolutely could if you want
to build some custom functionality in
absolutely absolutely
that's that's a whole other like ball of
worms if you go into building your own
custom application with view and custom
routing things like that custom you know
URLs there are SEO concerns there but
there's there's ways around it I don't
know all those and I couldn't that's a
whole other class yes yes but if you're
using WordPress just as it is a problem
there yeah yeah okay cool got you guys
out 2:36 pretty good I think you know a
good time to relax sure yeah
like yes that is an awesome question how
did I learn of UJS I did just learn it
myself
I used Linda I had a decent course but
honestly front-end masters if you guys
have ever heard of that website there's
a good tutorial on there by Sarah
Dresner and she's fantastic she's like a
developer advocate for view j/s and
she's got if you just search Sherratt
sarah Dresner she's got tons of content
out there about view and she's fantastic
about tutorials she does a little bit
but it's basically kind of the concepts
she talks more about not not
specifically WordPress but as far as
like actual specifically WordPress I
don't think there's I mean I may have to
put some stuff out there there we go
I appreciate it any other questions no
cool all right
thank you all for coming I appreciate it
[Applause]